so most of the videos on vitamin are
directed to entrepreneurs but today I
want to talk to the employees who also
follow value taemin but you're thinking
about maybe one day becoming an
entrepreneur you just don't know what to
do next listen there's ten things I want
you to be doing before thinking about
entrepreneurship I remember when I
worked at Bally Total Fitness and I had
a job and it was comfortable and I had a
salary and it was good for me and I
wanted to become a business owner I
wanted to become an entrepreneur but
there's a few things that I have to do
before I made that decision I'm going to
cover with you here today and by the way
I want you to know it ain't for
everybody so when I go through it you
may say I can't do that
I can't do this well maybe it ain't for
you some of your right into it here ten
things number one you got to learn how
to self motivate I get too many messages
man that people tell me how do you
motivate yourself can you say actually I
get snap snap chat messages Marya people
send me messages saying Pat can you give
me a motivational content today for me
to get motivated like if you don't know
how to self motivate yourself cross this
thing out if you do not know how to self
motivate yourself and get yourself up
fired up like this business isn't for
you because in a world of business
you're alone there's not going to be
somebody telling you amazing there's
going to be actually people on the
complete opposite side saying how
horrible you are constantly finding your
leaks think about it this way here so
this maybe make sense to you any athlete
that first gets into the league
everybody picks out him he does know how
to play defense he doesn't know how to
do this either it takes six seven eight
years until they made me want a
championship then they get off their
back same as the same as becoming an
entrepreneur you got to learn to keep
yourself tough you got to learn how to
play heard you got to learn how to stay
motivated and get your people motivated
so you got to learn how to self motivate
before you become an entrepreneur number
two save save save save your money I
saved my money when I worked at Bally's
I was working at Bally's but I was
saving that money I was setting aside
they want to because I knew long-term I
was going to be in sales I didn't know
what I was going to sell and I didn't
know if I was going to stay as an
employee forever because I wanted to
figure
to make more money I didn't know sales
was it but I did know that I needed my
money testify once fully commissioned
what am I going to do 500 fully
commissioned safe safe state number
three learn how to sell today we had an
entrepreneur that came here he may be in
the next vlog that will dot on a pulp if
you're going to put him on though or not
we'll figure it out but he came today
his idea was he has a app that he's
designing that's for what that's for
[Music]
housecleaning so for instance I'm in
Houston I want to do a house come on a
house Clooney who come to my house
tomorrow to clean it up I get on there I
booked him for hours my house was 2,000
square feet the pricing was going to be
a hundred twenty bucks and somebody
comes to my house that's what he's
designing he comes here Mario invites
him to come to the office he's
flabbergasted he's got five to ten
minutes with us and he speaks for ten
minutes you know what I asked him I
asked him the final question do you know
how to sell he says I do
I said I'm telling you don't know how to
sell he says what do you mean I said ten
minutes you're here you haven't asked a
single question yet you're just talking
talk and talk and talk and talk and talk
and talk and talking so your business is
not going to work if you don't know how
to sell you got learn how to sell so as
an entrepreneur if you're an employee
right now you're working where you're
working at if you don't learn how to
tell what he thing happens all of a
sudden become an entrepreneur you learn
how to sell you've got to learn how to
sell so before you make that plunge of
becoming an entrepreneur full-time learn
how to sell number four work work for
one yeah work for one work under an
entrepreneur work closely with a CEO
shadow one see what they do see what's
different about him and I'm talking
about one that's today an entrepreneur I
hear a lot of people that say you know I
work for a a 72 year old very successful
entrepreneur who made a lot of his money
but he golfs every day do you think
that's not who you want to work with you
want to work with the entrepreneur that
is starving but it's on his way up so
you can learn from him I remember one
time a guy called me and then was Brian
it was six o'clock in the morning I pick
up the call he says I have a shot at
working with this guy with this guy and
this guy who do you think I should be
working with you know what I told him I
said me he said come on Patrick why you
I said 100 percent
he says tell me why I said do you want
to work with somebody that tells you
stories on what they used to do when
they were 20 years ago or if you want to
work with somebody that's doing it today
they're working 1800 hours a week
because during the hunt if they don't
they're going to be out of business I'm
that guy you should be working directly
with me
week later we had a meeting at PF Changs
they started working with us why because
that's how you learn the most number
five network build contacts
relationships whatever you're doing
everything to you is just relationship
relationship relationship relationship
relationship we just had a call writing
with a guy that may also be on the blog
I just got back from Half Moon Bay I was
that happen about an aig event this past
week that was a very big event as you
just got a new CEO and a lot of other
things that we had to have a meeting
with over there when I came back he's
talking about he wants to invest it's a
big number that he wants to invest we're
not talking five million dollars we're
talking a lot of money that they want to
invest and we're having this
conversation together and as we're
having a conversation together Tom and I
start talking this whole thing
relationship came from 15 different
contacts led to this
okay so network build contact you never
know who's going to introduce you to
people send me a message and they say
how do I find an investor Patrick how
what do you mean how do you find an
investor if you're a rookie entrepreneur
make a list of everybody you know today
and then spread them out them by the way
that could be a whole different episode
spread them out
who knows who who knows who who knows
who who knows who who knows who and then
from their context as you're starting as
an employee you want to become an
entrepreneur that plundered you no
decision you want to make make a lot of
build a lot of contacts number six work
80 hours a week for 12 to 24 months and
see if you can do it or not while I
worked at Bally's I worked 80 hours
every single week as an employee and
they only paid me for you know $6 an
hour or $7 an hour or $5 an hour
whatever the number was because it was
commissions but I worked 80 90 hours per
week I was at the gym from morning till
night every day I was at the gym you
know why because I wanted to see
if I had what it takes to work because
if you don't know how to work 80 hours a
week as an employee you are definitely
not going to be making it as an
entrepreneur if you go full-time and you
want to make a business you're going to
be required to work regularly I think a
lot of times people have this idea that
you become an entrepreneur because when
you become an entrepreneur going to
become a millionaire and all this other
summand don't get me wrong that
eventually happens I mean it took me a
few years and then it happens and you
have the money in the lifestyle all this
other stuff but you going to becoming an
entrepreneur to create something and and
there's a risk that constantly that's
being taken to to want to grow the
business so if you don't know how to
work hard and you lose your edge boom
somebody comes and takes the market away
from you because you lost your edge so
if you don't know if you have it you're
right now working nine to five one to
work 80 hours a week at your job and see
what happens I'm dead serious with you
first of all you may get some crazy
promotions out of nowhere I think you
may be there and having real direct
private conversations with the CEO
because the CEO is there and you haven't
like my gosh CEO sees me every night I
leave after him I come before him what
the hell is going on who is this guy who
I just got working so hard work 80 hours
a week for 12 to 24 months to see if
you've got it or not next research learn
how to research and learn fast learn how
to research I think this this this this
thing about researching again that's a
whole different thing that people we can
probably do one how to research
something right could be an episode I
think researching is a skill you got a
research who's connected to who this
kind of what's this thing all about what
is this product all about what is this
guy why did it come up with this why did
this happen what does this law have to
do with this what is you got to learn
how to research okay and you get to the
bottom of something like this guy's
connected to this guy now I get why this
guy saying this enough oh this is stone
it makes sense and you get the click I
figured out what's going on here so you
gotta learn how to research and learn
fast
number eight build an audience back in
the days in ninety nine when I worked at
Bally's there was no Facebook I think
Facebook was Paul Woods Facebook oh
three or Oprah I'm gonna say February of
Oh is when I want to say Facebook what
said there was nothing MySpace I think
was all 102 I don't know when myspace
was but
nothing at Valley so there was no way to
build an audience but the way I build an
audience I build with everybody that was
a member at the gym I build an audience
with all the people I worked at
different valleys I build a relationship
there but build an audience build an
audience on social media build an
audience on snap on Facebook on
Instagram on YouTube on Twitter figure
out a way to build an audience with your
voice number 9 as you're going through
with this and you're making a decision
to go here start becoming self-aware and
aligned about what your own strengths
and weaknesses are like figure that part
out maybe you know what I never knew I
was like for me I never knew I was going
to be good in sales until I started
working at Bally's I mean I used to sell
at 10 years old but I really started
realizing I can be pretty good at the
sales thing right and then I started
realizing pressure what happens in
pressure you know deadlines when we have
numbers we have to hit in sales we had
close outs on Thursdays I'm ok with this
there was another guy one of my managers
I work with he was my boss he couldn't
hack it himself but he was my boss great
guy a sweetheart um the one thing I'll
never forget about him he always told me
just Pat you curse too much because I
just got on the army so every other word
out of my mouth was a curse word he's
got to slow this thing down I'd be
selling and cursing non-stop so he would
always work with me on that but I
remember was Thursday close out and we
haven't had our numbers yet he would be
panicking there's a guy named Tony
Wilson would call in and no one wanted
to pick up Tony's come but I would pick
up the call Tony what's going on why are
you bothering us it's not done yet let
me finish up my date can I call you back
at midnight yes didn't want to answer
the phone call then phone we would get
to three sales how I'm going to walk
away I'm going to Jim I'd walk around I
would say hey hey how you doing House
working sometimes
but who do you know right now that's
looking for a membership why are you so
why are you working out alone don't you
call your friends here let's get them to
become a member man one who can you call
right now can come to the gym tough to
come to the gym I would go through the
members that are working out and I would
get them to call their friends to come
to the gym and out selling memberships
that night and boom we would hit our
numbers right but it was it was you kind
of figuring out how to make that part
happen so you're on your strengths and
industries I like
sailes I like numbers I started looking
at which industries gave a life good
life like I saw too many guys in real
estate that we're still selling in their
30th year and working on Sundays I saw
way too many guys in mortgages that were
still selling I started looking at
stocks where market that was a serious 7
guy market would go up it was great
Marquis would go on if they they were
afraid of answering the phone calls and
all this stuff I looked at
pharmaceutical sales if you got a good
drug and what was somebody was good
because the doctors would constantly
order there was so many different things
I looked at and then I realized I liked
insurance I chose insurance why I
thought guys 10 years down the line 20
or something like good personal life
kids went to private schools good life a
lot of money you know you had an
opportunity make real real good money
like 5 million year 10 million years
some even more than that so that
opportunity was attractive but you learn
it here on what you're going to be doing
next and last but not least 10 deaths
ground you got to put yourself in
situations where your backs against the
wall let me tell you what that is let me
tell you what it is okay
deaths ground situations before you
become an entrepreneur because death
grant for entrepreneurs every day baby
you're on the death ground every single
day you are on death ground as an
entrepreneur but even more when you're
start-up entrepreneurs so take a
deadline that seems crazy go hit it say
yes and take responsibility for certain
projects and go hit it during some what
I'm saying to you take that deadline
that no one wants to touch because
they're afraid of coming through I'm at
an event and everybody's asking me what
do you think about the transition
somebody got promoted somebody came down
and one guy retired what do you think
about this whole move you know what I
said too in front of everybody and in
front of the guy that works directly and
I want you to go tell him because that's
exactly how I feel in a nice to notice
said what do you think about the new
promotion of this guy I said I'm a
little concerned he said why is that I
said he plays it too safe and so what do
many plays are too safe I say you see in
this industry you can get
after 25 years of being in a business
you can get a $300,000 your salary you
go to four hundred five hundred thousand
dollar your salary and you play it so
safe because you don't want to ruffle
any feathers and take any risks because
if you do you could possibly be fired
whereas a gala kebabian moshe a former
CEO of AIG that if you go watch some of
this guy's interviews gutsy guy i've
seen the sky in rooms talking cursing
every other word just a feisty guy that
went to the government asked for one
hundred eighty three billion dollars
from the government to save AIG and it
comes back and says not only am i gonna
give the taxpayer the money back but i'm
also going to give him interest and no
other company that when it got money
from the insurance government did that
he gave the government one hundred
eighty three billion dollars back plus
twenty three billion dollars of interest
i think four years later historically
they're considering him one of the best
fields if not be beyond the financial
industry period baba Moshe I said I'm
concerned because you're not a death
ground guy you're not a back against the
wall type of guy you're a plate safe
type of a guy it's why he's an employee
you do like this boom you're dead
hesitation no hesitation someone's
taking you out it's just what's going to
happen that's the world of business if
you play it safe and if you don't want
to put your yourself in a death grand
type of situations sometimes an investor
partners going to come up to instance we
need this money to be double right this
time we need this product to be
delivered by this time you don't know
how to do it you got to get on the call
and figure out a way to get this person
to deliver on all this other stuff to
get to that point so ten things that I
want you to do then ask yourself are you
ready some of you guys may be watching
the same pad I'm afraid it's eighty
hours a week then for 12 to 24 months
yeah I'm afraid of all this other things
that you're talking about I'm just
telling you the truth right now you want
to do it do it you don't want to do it
you don't do it by the way 90% of people
are not going to do this what I just
talked to you about if you're watching
this as the employee you're saying I
want to do it go take up the challenge
and update me on top of progress you're
making here on snapchat send me a
message a bit David 19 on snapchat let's
make the snapchat thing a little bit
bigger send me a message and tell me
about the progress you're making with
this year
as you're building your business and
last but not least our friendly pillow
here 1 million subs if you haven't
stopped to value taemin yet click on the
button here to subscribe and click on
the notification button can we make this
notification button are you a little bit
bigger Paul let's make it a little bit
bigger I can can we do like this click
on this alert button right next to
subscribe should be Wonder first to get
the videos every time they come up on
value Taemin and if you got any
questions thoughts about today's episode
comment on the bottom and if you got
some of your friends I need to watch it
as well share with
[Music]